So, pipeline is basically a mechanism for
connecting the output of one program
directly - conveniently - into the input of
another program. So that you can do, in
effect, two stages of processing just by
saying "program-1, vertical bar - that's the
pipeline symbol - second program". And what
that does is to start both programs and
take the output quietly from the first
one and stick it into the input of the
second one and then of course you can
have multiple of those.
Before that, the way that people connected programs --
but first I think they often didn't think of
connecting programs at all; you thought
of each program as its own thing, and it
would produce some output.
>>Sean: So you might put a few numbers into it
by punch card or whatever, it would sort them,
you'd take that output, and then take that one
literally ... connect the next program.
>>BWK: Right, yeah.
You do that, as it were manually. Unix had the
idea of file redirection, which made that
syntactically easy. The new invention was
to say, "Hey wait a minute, we could put an
operator to do that right in the shell," the
command line interpreter.
And then that made it a lot easier to do,
and it also encouraged people to, if the
mechanism wasn't clean already, retrofit
cleanliness into the implementation.
I think it is a new idea with UNIX as
far as I know.  I have somewhere in my
collection of historical documents a
page that Doug McIlroy wrote in 1964
saying what we want to do is a mechanism
for screwing programs together... connecting
programs together just like screwing
pieces of garden hose together, and that's
the model.  And then I think it was
probably three or four years later and I
don't know how it came about, but it just
got done, and literally in a very very short
period of time.
>>Sean: So basically the pipe is like
pumping water into a garden...
>>BWK: Yeah. And you just screw on another
length of garden hose if you want to do
further processing.
Garden hose doesn't process
in that same sense,
but it's a pipeline in the sense that you see in
certain kinds of manufacturing processes,
or something like that, where there's just
stages of processing.
>>Sean: What's the benefit of that
rather than just writing one big
massive program that just does everything
for you?
>>BWK: Well, first you don't have to write the
one big massive program.  You've got
existing smaller programs that may
already do parts of the job.  And having
smaller programs is better than having
massive programs, so that's one thing.
Another is that it's possible that the
amount of data you're processing would not
fit if you stored it in a file, if you
took the output of one program and had
to store it totally before you put it
into the next program.  It might not fit
because remember we're back in the days
when discs on these things had, if you
were lucky, a megabyte or two of data, not
a gigabyte or a terabyte, but a megabyte. And so you
couldn't instantiate necessarily the
output of a program before passing it on
to the next program.  So the pipeline
never had to instantiate the whole
output.
>>Sean: So by "instantiate", that's "store," is it?
Yes, store it. A big word for storing.
And so that meant so that you could kind of just
sneak things through without having to
do this
along the way.  So that would be another example.
And then it was just keeping track of the
intermediate files could be a nuisance,
cleaning up the mess afterwards -- all of
those things went away with the pipeline
mechanism where you just said,
"Hey, this is what I want to do:
this, this, this, in order."
>>Sean: Give me one result at the end of it?
>>BWK: Give me one result at the end of it.
>>Sean: Is that something that's still used today ...?
>>BWK: Oh, absolutely. It's still fundamental mechanism.
You use it all the time. You don't even think
about it at this point.  It's just part of it.
It took a while to get retrofitted I
think into let's say Windows but it's an absolutely
integral part of any UNIX-based system,
has been since, since the late sixties.
Just by taking existing programs, tools
like grep and wc and sort, and somewhere
in there I could throw in AWK if I
wanted to do slightly more
complicated kind of processing.  So all of
these things are using UNIX tools with
glued-together pipelines in ways that
were not thought of in the original
design.  That's the critical
observation, and that's the reason why these
little programs are often much more
useful than the very big, monolithic
one which does whatever it does, but
nothing else.  It's definitely an instance
of "don't reinvent the wheel."
Other people have done a lot of useful things
for you, and the ingenuity and often a lot
of fun of just saying, "Hey, I don't have
to do anything here except glue
together things that somebody else did
for me already."
>> Sean: I may be getting the wrong end
of the stick - or another cliche will come to me
in a minute - but is this where libraries come from then?
>> BWK: So you can think of
programs like grep and wc and sort as in
effect libraries, but libraries of programs
that stand alone, rather than libraries
of code which is linked, more or less
permanently, with other pieces of code.
So it's a library mechanism but in
some ways at a higher level, and the programs
are really independent of each other.